bonjour de conflits sociaux aujourd'hui
à la une de l'actualité à commencer par
les suites de la crise à la ferso les
employés de la société d'équarrissage
ont en effet décidé de passer à l'action
ce matin en organisant une opération
escargot entre agen et toulouse
à l'heure qu'il est les manifestants
viennent d'arriver devant le conseil
régional
demain devrait avoir lieu une nouvelle
réunion des préfets pour tenter de
trouver une solution à ce problème qui
dure je vous le rappelle depuis le 6
avril
autre point chaud là qu'aux phases à
riscle les employés de l'usiné d'andré
sont en effet en grève ils veulent
forcer la direction à divulguer son plan
social
depuis hier le personnel empêchent tout
mouvement des semi remorques chargés de
livrer les matières premières ou de
prendre livraison des sacs d'angle
manifestation cet après midi à 15 heures
des étudiants en médecine de toulouse
ils se disent alarmés par la réforme de
la formation médicale et ont déposé un
préavis de grève pour le 29 avril au dub
mouvementée hier à rabastens ou des
gangsters ont eu un accident de voiture
en sortant de l'agencé du crédit
agricole qu'il venait de cambrioler
l'un d'eux a été arrêté mais le butin
estimé à 10 millions de centimes n'a pas
été retrouvée à seysses et encore le
crédit agricole qui était visé le
malfaiteur s'est emparé d'environ 20000
francs avant de prendre tranquillement
la fuite c'est la troisième fois en un
an que cette agence est visité le
premier vol de la mini navette spatiale
hermès aura lieu en 1999 c'est du moins
ce qu'a annoncé alain madelin
le ministre de l'industrie est toujours
dans l'espace à noter la première
correction d'orbites du satellite
français spot qui a eu lieu hier à
toulouse
cette manoeuvre a été effectuée par le
cnes le centre national d'études
spatiales en sport à noter simplement
aujourd'hui le début à tarbes du tournoi
cadet de rugby 300 jeunes rugbymans
participent à cette manifestation et ce
qui ne gâche rien l'entrée est gratuite
le temps il est toujours beau et chaud
grâce à l'anticyclone qui est
actuellement sur la france
un léger vent venu du sud est soufflera
de manière irrégulière et avec des
rafales
la météorologie nationale prévoit pour
les jours à venir un temps lourd et
orageux mais rassurez vous cet après
midi les températures devraient
avoisiner les 20
3° il va y avoir de la foire à toulouse
dès demain le parc des expositions va en
effet accueillir pendant 11 jours la
foire internationale s'est tâté de cette
année le thème retenu la bande dessinée
xiii dessinateur auront ap lance une
planche à dessin original puisqu'il
s'agit d'une palissade longue de 100
mètres sur laquelle ils pourront laisser
libre cours à leur imagination
d'ailleurs vous allez en savoir plus
dans quelques instants puisque l'invité
de gérard morel et monsieur jacques
lacassagne le président de la foire
internationale
jean marc morandini vous savez tout vous
êtes parfait effectivement